[Música]
Ecuador sigue haciendo frente a una
espiral de violencia en el servicio
carcelario y a la vez llueven críticas
sobre el gobierno del presidente
Guillermo lasso por no atender este tema
en lo que va a tener 2022 los motines se
han cobrado la vida de al menos siempre
esos desde el 2020 las cifras ya llega a
450 presos que han fallecido en los
diferentes motines que sean que han
tenido lugar en ese país suramericano el
servicio nacional de atención integral a
personas privadas de libertad tiene a su
cargo 36 cárceles en todo el país
el director de esta entidad pública
Pablo Ramírez anunció su retiro del
cargo dejando aún más a la deriva al
sistema carcelario ecuatoriano los
constantes motines las muertes y las
disputas entre pandillas y grupos
ligados al narcotráfico se han
convertido en un cóctel perfecto para
una crisis que el gobierno no ha podido
hacer frente y tampoco ha podido
comenzar a revertir el comité permanente
de defensa de los Derechos Humanos a
cuestionado el rol del Estado
ecuatoriano ha considerado también
catalogar la crisis carcelaria como un
genocidio porque Más allá de lo que el
estado no ha hecho en esto se ve en los
esfuerzos insuficientes para evitar las
matanzas tampoco ha hecho no ha tomado
ningún tipo de medidas para evitar el
ingreso de las armas de las municiones
explosivos a las diferentes cárceles de
este país lo que deja en evidencia que
también hay un sistema completamente
corrupto e infiltrado por las bandas
criminales
Por qué está fuera de control entonces
la crisis carcelaria en Ecuador A qué se
debe la incapacidad del gobierno del
presidente lazo y qué tan permeado por
el crimen está el sistema carcelario
ecuatoriano lo vamos a analizar vamos a
conversar sobre este tema y para eso
Hemos invitado a saudia levoyer ella es
periodista docente Universitaria también
está con nosotros Mario pazmiño Él es
consultor general en seguridad y defensa
exdirector de inteligencia de Ecuador y
también es catedrático de la universidad
uniandes en la ciudad de Quito ustedes
nuestros televidentes también les
recuerdo que pueden ser parte del debate
de esta conversación del análisis por
supuesto dejen sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
estamos en Twitter en Facebook en
instagram nos encuentran como arroba el
debate_f24 y @santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal el numeral es el debate f24 no
olvide también que todos los contenidos
de este programa los encuentra también
en podcast estamos diferentes
plataformas por supuesto estamos en
Apple podcast en Spotify en deezer y en
TuneIn
Muy bien pues le doy la bienvenida
entonces a nuestra primera invitada
saudia en la ciudad de Quito para
comenzar con El Punto de partida crisis
carcelaria sin fin tal cual como vemos
anunciado en la promo de este programa
que es lo que sucede allí saldría desde
su punto de vista adelante bienvenida Y
gracias buenas tardes bueno la crisis
subcarcelaria como ustedes bien
anunciaban empieza hace dos años y ahí
está constantes matanzas lo que hay ahí
es un problema que no hay una idea Clara
de Qué hacer con las cárceles no es
solamente un tema de hacinamiento esto
ya ha estado más que diagnosticado se ha
dicho que de hecho el comité que
intervino en la matanza que hubo Hace
algunos meses y que estuvo presidido por
gente que ha trabajado con pandillas eh
dice que está las cosas bien
diagnosticas el problema es como esto se
puede articular en una política de
seguridad integral en el país porque las
cárceles están reflejando la violencia
de las cárcel Lo está reflejando la
violencia que hay en las calles el
Ecuador Lamentablemente se ha convertido
en uno de la ciudad de los países más
peligrosos especialmente la ciudad de
Guayaquil que bueno es por ser una
ciudad grande pero hay problemas en
esmeraldas en sucumbíos y en buena parte
de la costa por el tema del narcotráfico
es la opinión de estadia en nuestra
primera invitada ahora le doy la palabra
a Mario también en la ciudad de Quito
crisis carcelarias sin fin Mario que es
lo que está pasando y sobre todo lo que
llama la atención es esa incapacidad que
hay para hacer frente a los diferentes
motines evitar que esto suceda al
interior de las cárceles
gracias buenas tardes un cordial saludo
para los televidentes y un cordial
saludo también para savia a ver lo que
tenemos al momento en el contexto
carcelario primero hay que decirlo
frontalmente existe una improvisación
gubernamental y al hablar de una
improvisación gubernamental estoy
diciendo falta de políticas criminales
claras definidas y políticas públicas
que aterricen al tema de la solución de
problemas carcelarios eso es de primer
punto el segundo punto indudablemente
Son la presencia de carteles
internacionales que a través de megas
bandas controlan los centros carcelarios
que se han convertido en verdaderos
santuarios del crimen organizado
tercer elemento que es sumamente
importante eso es la corrupción el nivel
de corrupción es tan grande que no
podemos decir que el estado como tal
controla los centros carcelarios o
ejerce una soberanía sobre el espacio
territorial de estos centros carcelarios
estamos equivocados en eso pues quienes
controlan son las mega bandas quienes
administran y quienes dirigen los
centros carcelarios son estas
estructuras delictivas que tienen
constante y permanente diría yo
enfrentamiento entre sí porque cada
pabellón es considerado un santuario y
cada santuario se lo defiende a sangre y
fuego Esto es lo que genera
permanentemente estas fricciones por el
control del espacio al interior del
centro carcelario sí tenemos una
referencia importante
se dice que hay una cuestión de
corrupción No hemos hecho nada con
relación al tema este se ha pedido al
gobierno que hagan una reingeniería
total del sistema carcelario que es
sumamente vital para poder
reducir los niveles de violencia e
inseguridad que existen pero
lamentablemente no se han hecho este
tipo de acciones y seguimos en una yo
diría voráginen permanente de
inseguridad y de lo que es violencia
hago la Rondalla inversa continuó con
Mario ya le voy a dar la palabra a
saudia en unos minutos eh Mario entonces
con esta panorama que usted dice audios
nos han explicado Además este es un tema
que hemos venido cubriendo a lo largo de
estos dos años aquí en el debate de
France 24 Tal parece que el gobierno de
Guillermo lasso y usted me aclarará a
Mario no tiene un plan de seguridad
carcelaria diseñado o está en proceso de
desarrollo o simplemente no existe
dentro de la política de este gobierno
darle prioridad a la seguridad
carcelaria pese a estos hechos que están
desarrollando allí
puede existir una política carcelaria
pero no se aplica como tal la política
carcelaria no hay un proceso de
seguimiento y evaluación de la misma lo
que sí no existe en el país es una
política criminal en donde todas las
instituciones del estado se orienten a
reducir los niveles de violencia y
criminalidad al interior de los centros
carcelarios eso no existe al momento y
al no existir tanto políticas públicas
como políticas criminales es sumamente
difícil de que se puedan articular
planes sectoriales y planes
institucionales entonces cada uno de los
centros carcelarios actúa bajo una
diferente dinámica para solucionar los
problemas que están presentes ahí eso
por un lado por otro lado hay que
decirlo los niveles de de
directivos y cabe el término manifestar
Así que son los encargados de organizar
y administrar los centros carcelarios no
son técnicos no son seleccionados
adecuadamente y al no ser selecciona
adecuadamente usted entra en un cierto
tipo de
designación lo que llamamos acá en el
país a dedo o sea designaciones en las
cuales pues son cuotas políticas sin
pensar que lo que se necesita
verdaderamente en el sistema carcelario
son técnicos como criminólogos
antropólogos sociólogos especialistas de
negociación especialistas en
rehabilitación social que verdaderamente
vayan a contribuir a solucionar el tema
que hemos hecho por parte del Estado
hemos designado a policías y militares
para que sean cargo de los centros
carcelarios eso fue el peor error porque
no estamos preparados para eso por un
lado y por otro lado qué es lo que ha
dejado este tipo de selección cerca de
400 muertos y el estado tendrá que
responder ante organismos
internacionales y también ante la
justicia nacional por esta
irresponsabilidad porque el artículo
2001 de la Constitución es muy claro y y
específicamente que el estado es el
responsable por la vida y los derechos
de los privados de libertad claro no
existir esta situación por parte del
Estado Pues hay una deficiencia tremenda
y estructural del mismo claro importante
ese punto que deja Mario sobre la mesa
le doy ahora la palabra a saudia si
tiene algo que complementar o decir o
contradecir esa odia con respecto a lo
que dice Mario y le extiendo un poco la
pregunta y es tal vez lo que le preocupa
la comunidad internacional es porque el
gobierno del presidente lazo no logra
atender esta crisis carcelaria que como
vemos y como hemos tratado en este
programa tiene ramificaciones que van
hacia el narcotráfico hacia la
delincuencia común y otro tipo de de
aristas no es solamente la violencia por
el hacinamiento sino que esto tiene
diferentes puntos clave que se unifican
en esa crisis carcelaria es que tanto
como dijo Mario como al principio yo en
la intervención que dice esto es un
problema que
de lo que pasa en las cárceles lo que
está pasando en el país en general no
hay una política de seguridad en el país
se ha dicho que se va a anunciar en los
próximos días Cuál va a ser esta
política hay también por ahí un plan
para hacer frente al tema del
narcotráfico algo parecido con lo que
ocurrió en Colombia con el plan Colombia
que es aproximadamente por 5 mil
millones que es lo que se está diciendo
pero no se conocen detalle qué es lo que
está pensando realmente el gobierno
hacer y si es grave la situación porque
o el control el control de las cárceles
es bastante difícil tomando en cuenta
que son espacios que cada grupo criminal
que maneja lo controla Entonces cuando
entraron las comisiones a lo que quería
era justamente ver cómo la cárcel
realmente era retomada pero yo muchas
veces me pregunto es retomada realmente
o solo mantiene cierta tranquilidad y
cierta Paz al interior porque esta
guerra de bandas empezó hace mucho
tiempo cuando se le permitió que el
narcotráfico entre la manera como ha
entrado Entonces el gobierno lo que
tiene que hacer es presentar una
política Clara alrededor Qué es lo que
está pensando hacer cómo lo va a
afrontar pero esa es la parte que no la
hacen Entonces esto se convierte en un
apaguemos el incendio a la semana pasada
fueron 14 personas muertas y es que no
me equivoco en la cifra y varios heridos
y no pasa más O sea lo que se trata es
de contener es una cuestión reactiva
pero no hay nada propositivo Yo hasta
ahora no lo veo y el gobierno Lleva más
de un año en funciones no hay nada
preventivo para hacer frente a esta
situación saudia continúo con usted
también llama mucho la atención los
constantes las constantes críticas que
ha habido en diferentes medios de
comunicación y también a través de las
redes sociales sobre el desproporcionado
uso de la fuerza que hubo sobre todo con
los hechos en la cárcel de cotopaxi y en
la penitenciaría del litoral en donde
Vimos a las fuerzas del orden
ecuatorianas también
casi Que reprimiendo la presencia de los
familiares que estaban allí pidiendo
información por sus familia que están
detenidos que están privados de su
libertad Y esto quedó en evidencia en
las redes sociales aquí también hay
llamado de atención para el gobierno y
para las fuerzas del orden y como usted
dice como no hay nada preventivo
simplemente reactivo y se está abusando
del uso de la fuerza es que cuando no
hay información la gente entra en
desesperación con tantos muertos que han
habido en el Ecuador por el tema de las
cárceles que se escuche o que se empiece
a escuchar en la red social en Twitter
sobre todo que hay problemas en tal
centro penitenciario la gente entra en
pánico porque son sus familias hay
muchos de los fallecidos que ni siquiera
estaban o eran miembros de las bandas
que están en una constante guerra sino
que son personas que están ahí detenidas
ahí están en la mitad porque si logran
mantenerse por fuera de los grupos está
bien porque también dentro de la cárcel
les hay un tema de extorsión constante
Entonces cuando entra la policía y
entran los militares es para tratar de
contener cuando porque uno también puede
ver o se ha visto en algunos motines que
están disparando desde los techos
entonces
es todo un cruce ahí de cosas y ese es
el tema de cómo se está también
manejando la parte comunicativa en todo
este tema de las crisis de las crisis
que se producen en las cárceles Sí ya le
voy a preguntar por ese tema más audio
dejémoslo sobre la mesa el cubrimiento
que le están dando los medios de
comunicación la censura a la información
y también cómo están tratando a los
medios de comunicación por cubrir este
tema Ya vamos a hablar de ese tema paso
a preguntarle a Mario sobre este uso de
la fuerza por parte de las fuerzas del
orden ecuatorianas muy criticado y se
vuelve como otro frente de crítica para
el gobierno también
claramente no es la forma de responder a
este tipo de de crisis que se dan en las
cárceles en Ecuador el gobierno está
actuando de una manera que le va a jugar
en contra
indudablemente yo he manifestado
públicamente que un pie de fuerza
excesivo para un control en Estos
espacios cerrados es sumamente peligroso
y también hay que ser muy consciente de
que el nivel de violencia de
organización de equipamiento y de
armamento que tienen estas estructuras
delictivas al interior de los centros
carcelarios le obliga al Estado a
emplear una mayor dinámica de fuerza
para poder controlar esto de no hacer el
estado este empleo de fuerza yo diría en
algunos casos excesiva pues lo que
tendríamos de allá sería una masacre
mucho más grande fíjese que acá estamos
hablando nosotros de revueltas y
amotinamientos en los que existen
descuartizados existen personas
decapitadas incineradas donde los los
pedazos de cuerpos están regados por
todas partes entonces la policía y los
órganos de seguridad del Estado no
pueden quedarse al margen tienen
necesariamente que intervenir para
evitar que esa masacre se incremente en
el en el contexto del centro carcelario
que a veces tendrá que emplearse la
fuerza Sí tienen que emplear la fuerza
porque las agresiones que reciben desde
el otro lado me refiero yo desde los
privados de libertad no es que le
reciban allá con flores le reciben con
fusil con lanzagranadas con explosivos y
recientemente en el intento de ingreso
de la fuerza a uno de los recintos
penitenciarios para poder controlar esto
hubieron seis policías heridos y algunos
de gravedad ninguno de nosotros personas
de los privados de libertad estuvieron
heridos pero esa es la la dinámica que
se maneja en un en un centro carcelario
en donde el estado no tiene el control y
lo que trata de hacer el estado lo que
decía el presidente de la República en
algún caso vamos a tratar vamos vamos a
tratar de recuperar la soberanía del
centro carcelario Eso quiere decir que
el estado está reconociendo públicamente
de que no tiene el control en el centro
carcelario y una muestra palpable de eso
es lo que pasó hace unos 15 días atrás
en la penitenciaría del litoral en donde
se celebra un cumpleaños de uno de los
de capos de esta organización o de los
dirigentes de las mega bandas
con juegos pirotécnicos de un sinnúmero
de de de cosas de juegos artificiales
que justamente son completamente
prohibidos Eso quiere decir que no hay
control del estado y el estado No
administra ese centro carcelario quien
administra directamente pues son las
vegabandas y los micro carteles que
están ahí enquistados directamente en
Estos espacios territoriales relacionado
con eso que usted dice Mario un grupo
Pro derechos humanos emitió un informe
muy crítico hacia el gobierno
ecuatoriano en el que dice que ninguna
de las masacres carcelarias que han
tenido lugar en Ecuador desde el 2020 ha
existido una recuperación del control
total de las prisiones por parte del
estado es decir esto aparte de la
situación que se presenta allí por la
territorialidad entre las diferentes
bandas delincuenciales y grupos del
narcotráfico esto sigue siendo una olla
a presión a punto de estallar en donde
el estado tampoco va a poder dar un tipo
de respuesta adecuada no ha logrado ni
siquiera recuperar el control en esas
cárceles que usted está mencionando
también ahí cuál puede ser el primer
paso Qué puede hacer el gobierno para
recuperar ese control
básicamente hay varios estrategias que
tendría que aplicar el estado
inmediatamente primero es una decisión
política para una reingeniería total del
sistema carcelario a corto plazo voy a
dar algunas recomendaciones tiene que
manejar una política criminal real que
permita atender las necesidades de ese
de ese recinto carcelario que la Policía
Nacional sea la que tome el control del
centro carcelario porque lo que tenemos
acá es que hay cuatro instituciones que
están dentro de los centros carcelarios
y cada una de ellos le entrega la
responsabilidad a la otra y nadie les
hace responsable tiene que haber una
sola institución implementación de
control tecnológico en cada pabellón
incremento presupuestario que no lo
disponen al momento más bien hay una
reducción de ese incremento
presupuestario a mediano plazo que tiene
que hacerse erradicación de la
corrupción reactivación de las escuelas
de formación de guías penitenciarios
contingente de guías con formación
equipamiento armamento y salarios
adecuados de acuerdo a su función y
responsabilidad y por otro lado a largo
plazo tiene necesariamente que pensarse
en lo que se llama la privatización
carcelaria como una alternativa ante el
fracaso del gobierno en el control y la
administración de los centros
carcelarios su opinión la privatización
es una forma para poder salir de esta
espiral de violencia y en Ecuador y
luego continuó con usted para hablar del
tema informativo y del trato a la prensa
allí en Ecuador sobre este tema
Ok puedes puede ser una salida No de
hecho cualquier cosa que dé una
alternativa para el control de las
cárceles es sumamente importante porque
como país no podemos estar cada mes
máximo ya y matanzas y no hay una
decisión ahí Clara de Cómo afrontar el
problema Está súper diagnosticado lo que
falta ahí es decisiones y Claridad en
esas decisiones para saber Hacia dónde
va a ir el tema concreto de cárceles que
como repito debe estar anclado al resto
del tema de Cómo manejar la seguridad
del país porque no vamos a solventar
solamente una patita cuando los algunos
de los líderes de las de las bandas
estas están ahí adentro y siguen
manejando el negocio por allá afuera
Entonces eso toca es pensarlo de una
manera integral y a ir tomando acciones
en el corto plazo
en cuanto al tema de el manejo
informativo también ha habido muchas
críticas porque periodistas y también
incluso activistas de los Derechos
Humanos denunciaron que cuando estaban
allí cubriendo los hechos en la cárcel
del litoral en en guayas
hubo golpes hubo amenazas por parte de
las personas que estaban custodiando la
periferia del centro penitenciario el
cubrimiento de este tema es fácil el
acceso a la información el gobierno
esconde información precisamente porque
esta es una crisis que ha venido
constante desde que el presidente lazo
llegó a la presidencia y es poco como lo
estamos analizando acá lo que se hace
para poder mitigar el impacto de esta
crisis el cubrimiento de este de este
tema es audio es complicado para los
periodistas A ver es complicado pero
también creo que como periodistas
debemos tomar en cuenta ciertos
lineamientos que debemos respetar no
estamos ahí cubriendo una manifestación
que puede ser violenta pero no llega a
los grados de violencia que hay dentro
de las cárceles porque Mario ya les
comentó ahí se encuentra gente
decapitada descuartizada entonces lo que
yo entiendo es que si a uno le están
pidiendo que no pase pues hay que pasar
ahora de ahí que vayan al golpe ya es ya
hay un paso muy grande y eso sí no es
adecuado Pero no entiendo aquí en el
país hay el 911 que supuestamente debe
concentrar la información y ahí es
cuando uno dice qué es lo que está
pasando porque eso es una emergencia y
claro la prensa obviamente corremos al
lugar de los hechos para atender nuestra
propia versión pero tenemos que también
de alguna manera ir trabajando en
colaboración cuando ha caído momentos
críticos siempre ha habido como una
línea no que uno dice Bueno está bien
hasta aquí no voy a cruzar pero ya en
esto tenemos que ir pensandolo y
pensándolo un poco mejor Entonces yo
creo que ahí el gobierno tiene que
mejorar la entrega de información y que
sea información de calidad no sólo una
simple declaración y la prensa
obviamente tiene derecho a acercarse
pero también tiene que entender que Hay
momentos en que uno no puede cruzar
porque es demasiado violento o demasiado
inseguro el país no tiene esa cultura de
ese tipo de coberturas porque es la
primera vez que nos pasa entonces yo
también creo que por ahí vamos a tener
que ir aprendiendo de a poco de ambos
lados para ver cómo vamos mejorando el
tema de la información claro Mario qué
hay del tema de la infraestructura yo
daba el dato al inicio del programa que
el servicio nacional de atención
integral a personas privadas de libertad
tiene cerca de 36 cárceles en todo el
territorio ecuatoriano la
infraestructura
es deficiente ya hablamos del
hacinamiento Ya lo vamos a hablar más
adelante pero que hay de la
infraestructura Qué necesidades tiene
Ecuador en cuanto a la infraestructura
carcelaria
primero una corrección son 53 recintos
carcelarios de distribuidos en todo el
territorio nacional tres de estos son
cárceles
regionales en donde pues se han dado
principalmente las más importantes
masacres a nivel nacional y
consideremos que estas cárceles
regionales la una ubicada en la
provincia del guayas la otra en cotopaxi
y la otra en la provincia de Azuay estas
cárceles pues fueron construidas con el
propósito de reducir los niveles de
hacinamiento pero no se consideró
posteriormente que esto más bien amplió
la cantidad de detenciones porque
comenzamos a detener a personas y en eso
la justicia también tiene una
responsabilidad inmensa en este país
porque la justicia comenzó a ver ese
como un negocio un negocio mediante el
cual se colocaba a personas
sin sentencia ejecutoriada
contradiciendo lo que dice la norma
constitucional en el artículo 203 que
dice claramente que no puede estar ahí
en el recinto carcelario ninguna persona
que no tenga sentencia ejecutoriada en
el país existe al momento cerca de
16.000 personas que están allá sin
sentencia ejecutoriada contraviniendo la
normativa legal constitucional por lo
tanto porque están ahí porque no tienen
el dinero para pagar a jueces y Fiscales
para poder salir en libertad esa es una
realidad y gran parte de los muertos son
estas personas que están cruzadas entre
el juego disperso de Mega bandas o
bandas y pues terminan
siendo Víctimas de las mismas eso es lo
que sucede ahí al interior de los
centros carcelarios Pero por otro lado
también es importante manifestar y decir
que
estos centros carcelarios no tienen en
Sí una visión
que les permita orientarse hacia lo que
son la reinserción social y esto pues es
gravísimo porque cada uno de los centros
en su pabellón en la parte frontal de de
ingreso a cada uno de estos centros
cancelados dice centro de rehabilitación
social que no existe rehabilitación
social en este país y nadie puede decir
que verdaderamente exista ahí por eso es
lo que tenemos una reincidencia las
personas que logran salir después de
cumplirse condena reinciden en un 70%
regresa nuevamente a las a las a los
centros carcelarios y hay una
estigmatización social Entonces es
sumamente difícil que esa persona que
sale del centro carcelario pueda
reinsertarse en la sociedad eso por un
lado por otro lado también es
interesante manifestar lo siguiente que
al momento los centros carcelarios
necesitan mayor recurso mayor tecnología
para poder brindar en cierta forma las
diferentes vulnerabilidades y
debilidades que tienen no tienen
sistemas de seguridad apropiados para
proteger de Pabellón a pabellón existe
un candado pequeño que no lo tiene ni
los últimos guardias ni la policía las
llaves me refiero Yo sí tampoco los
señores Quién tiene la llave de la
puerta de cada uno de los pabellones son
cada uno de los de de los detenidos de
ese pabellón Entonces de qué seguridad
hablamos se necesitan sistemas de
inhibidores necesitan sistemas de
cámaras todas estos componentes que
estoy diciendo yo
han sido destruidos o han sido
y no existen en la realidad ahí añadimos
Entonces es audías dos puntos
importantes para entender esta crisis
uno la justicia sin eficiente la
impunidad y también los programas de
reinserción qué más se puede decir sobre
principalmente estos temas de
reinserción social el gobierno tampoco
Ha logrado ser efectivo en este tipo de
programas qué piensa usted
si el tema de la reinserción Es
realmente difícil la gente no es que
sale de la cárcel y puede conseguir un
trabajo más allá de la crisis económica
y falta de empleo que hay que hay en el
país pero hay un tema adicional que creo
que hay que toparlo insistentemente que
es el tema de la corrupción no no
solamente es un tema de impunidad sino
también hay un tema de corrupción muy
fuerte no sólo dentro de las cárceles
sino en diferentes estamentos del Estado
lo cual hace que la esta impunidad sea
cada vez más grave y más grande y el
tema de rehabilitación para devolverme a
su pregunta creo que no hay Hay cosas
muy pequeñas O creo que son de mucho
esfuerzo de algunos de los internos que
por ahí trata de escuchar perdón de
estudiar algo de aprender Alguna algún
oficio para ver qué es lo que puede
hacer porque recordemos que dentro de
las cárceles también ellos pagan por su
propia seguridad y tienen a sus familias
por fuera que tienen que conseguir
dinero para mantenerse y también para
pagar por la seguridad de sus seres
queridos En algunos espacios que están
tomados por estas bandas
de la justicia Entonces destacábamos
esta impunidad que es ineficiente y la
corrupción que hay saudia pero de
acuerdo a algunos estudios que hicieron
allí las autoridades en Ecuador y
algunos organismos internacionales dicen
y esto lo estaba mencionando en Mario lo
tocó en una de sus intervenciones
hay un abuso por parte de la justicia
ecuatoriana en cuanto a la prisión
preventiva
que es un mecanismo utilizado para tener
a la persona
bajo custodia antes de ir a un proceso
judicial Pero esto ha saturado
claramente las las prisiones Aquí hay
una mala interpretación de la justicia
es como dice Mario simplemente un
negocio que es mejor tener a las
personas detenidas en prisión preventiva
que darle otro tipo de beneficios antes
de hacer frente a la justicia o esto es
simplemente otro ejemplo más de la
corrupción ecuatoriana
hay un abuso en la cuestión de estas de
esta medida específica que es la la
orden de detención no pero ahora también
es que tenemos cada caso aquí en el país
O sea gente con grilletes que han estado
por entrar a juicios se han escapado han
dañado los grilletes Entonces yo creo
que ahí también hace falta un trabajo
Mucho más
efectivo de la justicia en el sentido de
determinar Quiénes son los que realmente
pudieran fugarse y quienes sí se pueden
defender en libertad Entonces sí hay un
tema de falta de garantías de falta de
gestión y obviamente es todo esto le
compete a la justicia y también a las
personas que hacen la investigación O
sea la fiscalía que es la que va Armando
los casos que permiten que los jueces
tomen ciertas decisiones Entonces yo no
podría descartar tampoco que hay este
tema de corrupción de por medio que
puede puede haberlo Pero también es un
tema de ineficiencia claro y Mario su
opinión sobre el tema de la corrupción y
la ineficacia de la justicia pero
hagamos
énfasis en el tema de la corrupción qué
tan permeado está el sistema por la la
descripción por
comprar a los jueces por estos grupos
delincuenciales que se apoderan de estos
centros reclusorios
básicamente el crimen organizado trata
de penetrar las estructuras
gubernamentales las estructuras de
control las estructuras judiciales y
también las estructuras sociales pero en
los centros carcelarios cada uno de
estos elementos lo que trata es de copar
rápidamente a los administradores de los
centros carcelarios comprar a los guías
de los centros carcelarios comprar el
primer círculo que es el de ingreso
hacia el centro carcelerado que está
controlado por la Policía Nacional todos
estos elementos directa o indirectamente
trabajan o colaboran con el crimen
organizado y con las megas bandas que
están ahí sino la pregunta que nos
podemos hacer todos es porque ingresan
permanentemente armamento al interior
del centro carcelario los señores del
snay que son los que administran
centrocacional disculpan a quienes a los
guías penitenciarios y los guías
penitenciarios culpan a la Policía
Nacional evidencias concretas hace una
semana atrás
miembros de la Policía Nacional con el
servicio activo llevando su chaleco
munición para entregar al interior a los
a los delincuentes que estaban al
interior del centro carcelario
armamentos que ingresan por todo lado
vulnerando todos los los filtros
entonces existe verdaderamente un nivel
de corrupción sumamente alto y elevado a
tal punto que como decía yo inicialmente
en esta entrevista no hay un control
quienes administran y quienes controlan
el centro carcelario son estas
organizaciones fíjese que en una Navidad
ingresó allá
un jacuzzi inmenso para que se vaya los
privados de libertad
entraron prostitutas entraron allá droga
entró whisky entonces sobre todo cómo
entra eso eso no puede entrar si no hay
una complicidad directa de los
funcionarios y de los miembros de esta
organización claro Claudia lo más
paradójico es que
estos días complicados para el sistema
carcelario ecuatoriano los hechos
recientes en la cárcel de cotopaxi y del
litoral llegan solamente días después de
una visita del vicepresidente de la
Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos que también es relator para las
personas privadas de la libertad del
señor estuardo ralon y destacó en su
informe después de visitar las cárceles
ecuatorianas los avances en la reducción
en el hacinamiento en el sistema
penitenciario ecuatoriano en líneas
generales es esto evidente o este señor
vio desde la Barrera lo que
verdaderamente pasa al interior de las
de las cárceles ecuatorianas Cuál es su
opinión
Pues sí que haya sido una una visión que
tuvo del momento porque hasta antes de
la nueva masacre parecía parecería o sea
por lo menos esa era como la imagen que
había que ya estaban las cosas más
tranquilas pero siempre estamos en una
cuestión reactiva entonces después viene
lo que se está conteniendo ahí y que es
como una olla de presión que cualquier
momento eso va a explotar y va a
explotar muy mal si ya ha estado
bastante malo yo creo que va a ponerse
peor Y en el tema del hacinamiento sí
puede que hayan movido algunos presos
porque de hecho lo han movido hay
algunos que incluso pidieron y después
de lo último que pasó en cotopaxi se
movilizó algunos detenidos a sobre todo
a Santo Domingo de los tsáchilas
entonces claro se está haciendo un censo
entonces dicen Bueno sí se está
trabajando en el tema del hacinamiento
pero el hacinamiento es solo uno de los
de los problemas que hay adentro el
problema mayor es el tema de cómo les se
les rehabilita y que no hay control por
parte del Estado dentro de las cárceles
me queda un minuto para finalizar el
programa Mario rápidamente su conclusión
lo que va a pasar en los próximos días
el presidente tomará decisiones
contundentes frente a esto o lo dejará
pasar como otro episodio más y veremos
otro motín en cuestión de semanas días
meses rápidamente por favor muy puntual
el presidente de la república no va a
tomar ninguna acción porque el estado
está básicamente paralizado y es un
estado reactivo qué es lo que va a pasar
de aquí a corto plazo se va a irradiar
esta crisis carcelaria va a generarse
una metástasis de violencia en los otros
centros carcelarios que ya comenzó
ellos En esta semana
rápidamente su conclusión para el cierre
del programa
bueno que si el gobierno no toma ninguna
decisión nos tenemos que ir preparando
para una situación mucho más complicada
No solo a nivel de las cárceles sino a
nivel de la seguridad en todo el país
asadura y a Mario les agradezco mucho
por haber estado con nosotros hoy haber
hecho ese análisis para la audiencia de
France 24 En nombre del equipo técnico
Les agradecemos su sintonía la
producción del programa estuvo a cargo
de Laura garzón y la producción de
invitados a cargo de Tania Herrera
Muchas gracias y Siguen con France 24
[Música]